uh like a couple of lessons ago a couple
of seconds ago yeah
uh i'm going to start today's lesson
with a video
um do i have to show you this video for
you to understand the concepts
that um we're about to learn answer no
but it's just so awesome that i can't
not show you so
this is about a minute long i hope you
enjoy
we slam into the atmosphere and develop
so much aerodynamic drag
our heat shield it heats up and it glows
like the surface of the sun
1600 degrees
mars is actually really hard to slow
down because it has just enough
atmosphere
that you have to deal with it otherwise
it will destroy your spacecraft
on the other hand it doesn't have enough
atmosphere to finish the job
we're still going about a thousand miles
an hour so
at that point we use a parachute the
parachute is the largest and strongest
supersonic parachute that we've ever
built
to date it has to be able to withstand
65 000 pounds of force even though the
parachute itself only weighs about 100
pounds
when it opens up that fast it's a neck
snapping nine g's
at that point we have to get that heat
shield off it's like a big lens cap
blocking our view of the ground to the
radar the radar has to take
just the right altitude and velocity
measurements at just the right time or
the rest of the landing sequence won't
work
so like i said i think it's pretty
awesome i remember the first time i saw
this this is for
nasa's mars curiosity rover by the way
and if you want to see the rest of the
video
you should absolutely go and google
after this lesson is finished
um seven minutes of terror you will find
that exact video
um to me i remember watching that the
first time and just being
astonished right science which has sort
of gotten us
you know all this incredible knowledge
and has you know landed us on mars
um it's uh a way of knowing things
that's via experimentation and i always
kind of wondered
yeah but how does that work when you're
going somewhere you've been trying
something you've literally never done
before
because it is you know millions of
kilometers away on another planet
how do you know that your parachute is
going to work that even though it is so
light
it can withstand that amount of force
it's going to slow you down to that kind
of velocity
and it's the mathematics of it right so
today
we are going to be rounding out you
believe it
mechanics with projectile motion you've
looked at projectile motion already in
extension 1 but we're going to push
further
because the projectile motion you know
about at the moment is imagining that
there is no medium
or that there is a medium that exerts
resistance
that is negligible so you can pretty
much forget about it right
and we've seen this before you get this
kind of very nice parabolic shape and
the vast majority of you
have encountered how to find that
particular what we call the equation of
path which is a parabola lots of weird
v's and g's and tan thetas and all that
kind of thing
but what we're going to do is we're in
extension 2 we're going to ratchet it up
and we're going to work out what happens
to projectile motion
when you think about resistance so you
can see i've got this example that we're
going to work through together
this afternoon and then there are some
questions we're going to work through
which
i just think are amazing that we can
understand these complex
physical systems using uh essentially
you know the differential and integral
calculus that you've learned over the
last
two years so let's have a go at this
together
a projectile is fired with velocity
vector v
equals and then you've got uh this
particular format we're using
vector notation to indicate the
horizontal and the vertical components
that's what you can see there the i
and the j which are our unit vectors um
across
and upward air resistance is
proportional to the velocity
and they give us as a result the
equations of motion so you can see here
here's the horizontal acceleration uh
which is
with proportion to the horizontal
velocity dx on dt
and then you've got the uh vertical
acceleration which is
there's the gravity which we've seen has
to be taken into account in
uh vertical resisted motion and then
here you've got that same constant
proportionality which sometimes by the
way
worth noting down i might jot it down
just so you see it
it's often given in this context a
specific name it's called the drag
coefficient for obvious names it's a
coefficient
that describes how much aerodynamic drag
there is so
shock horror you can see why they called
it that so then
if they give you these particular values
for k the drag coefficient and if we're
just going to go with gravity being 10
who needs 9.8 for this particular model
here's the question maybe you want to
jot this down because
this all of this working is not going to
all the question is not going to stay
there as i scroll down
find the horizontal displacement as a
function of time
find the vertical displacement as a
function of time and then what we're
going to do is we're going to smoosh
them together
and determine the cartesian equation of
motion what i just called the equation
of path
but it's going to be something a little
more complicated than the parabolas we
looked at in extension
1. so here's the um road map we're going
to have here
i'm going to walk you through finding
the horizontal
equation for displacement and then i'm
going to give you a nudge
into finding the vertical equation for
displacement
and i'm going to let you finish off that
work and then combine them together
and then we're going to draw some
conclusions from that once we arrive
okay so there's the roadmap and let's
begin
by just taking this particular
horizontal
differential equation that you can see
here and what i'm going to do
is i'm going to write it in dot notation
okay so you can see here we're using
uh live mixes you know dx on dt and all
that kind of thing
so because the left hand side there is
acceleration in dot notation i would
call that x
double dot and then on the right hand
side we've got
minus or negative k x dot there's the x
on dt
there's my horizontal velocity now i
just want you to stare at this
with me for a moment some of you
encountered this result before and so
you're like oh i instantly know what to
do here but others
of you will find this quite new what we
need to do is get from this
to mark this right the
horizontal displacement in terms of time
i need to introduce time
into here somewhere and it's a
differential equation which doesn't have
any um
any x's or t's in it yet um i need to
sort of get to there by integration
right now there's a bunch of different
ways to go about this but the quickest
way is to remember something that we
learned all the way back
in advance in one of the first
differential equations that you
encountered even though you didn't
necessarily get the language at the time
what you've got here is some function
right it's multiplied by this constant
and that's going to be the same as that
function's derivative
right you can see this is the derivative
with respect to t
of this does this ring any bells do we
know about a function
that when you multiply by a constant you
end up having
the same thing um but the next level
down
after differentiation do you recognize
this as
modeling something that exists in real
life and it's not just
air resistance i wonder if it's really
any pills for anyone does anyone want to
post in the chat if they're brave enough
um it's a pair of words that some of you
might recall
from an application of calculus uh shams
got it but go be brave charm put it put
it out there for everyone
so they can see because that's what we
should uh pop on the side of this
yeah very good so this is exponential
decay right and just as a bit of a
sort of flag for you right i want you to
remember this looks a whole lot like we
would write this a little differently
in exponential decay we might say
there's a maybe i'll say
an m rather than a p because p usually
indicates population
and we don't really want to think about
populations that are exponentially
decaying
especially under these circumstances so
if you've got like a mass like a
radioactive material right
and it's changed with respect to time if
it's a decay
situation it's going to look something
like this right minus
k m this is the differential equation
that you get
the rate of change is proportional to
how much stuff there is
um the more radioactive material you
have the faster it is decaying in giving
off that substance
so being that we can recognize this as
an exponential um
the solution to this differential
equation is an exponential decay
situation
what i can say is i can sort of infer
from that
that x dot which is kind of
corresponding to our
m if you like our mass in the you know
exponential decay situation
that's going to be equal to some a e
to the negative k t this is the sort of
stock standard
exponential decay situation that you can
get and all i need to do here is find
out what all of the constants
are there's only two of them a and k by
using the information
provided to us in the question and
that's going to enable us to find out uh
all the relative bits and pieces
okay so for starters what i can say is
that the
drag coefficient the k that we saw here
uh and which reappears
here in the front of this um this second
derivative right
it's going to be this same k over here
so that's going to be a fifth
right so i can actually just write this
is going to be
a e to the minus t on
five so this is my uh dx
on dt and i'm going to now try and find
out what a is using my initial
conditions so i can say when t equals
zero
what do i know about x dot
go back i i didn't give you much time to
write in the question there
go back to the top of the question it
tells you what the initial
you know velocity of projection is
through that vector it's in vector
notation right
so of those two which one is the
horizontal component you can tell me in
the chat right go ahead
pop the number in for me
very good thank you anger in first but
i'm sure several of you see it so
that i unit vector is multiplied by 15.
so that
is going to be my initial condition when
i'm just thinking about the horizontal
motion so from there i can say well okay
once i substitute t
equals 0 into here you can see
e to the power of 0 is just 1.
everything to the power of 0 that we're
dealing with is going to be equal to 1.
so therefore i'm going to get a
times 1 equals 15 because that's the x
dot
when time 0 is being evaluated so
therefore
i've got my coefficient there a equals
15.
so now i've got an equation for
horizontal velocity x dot
equals 15 e to the negative t on five i
think we wrote up above
okay now as promised what we're going to
do is we're going to use this
to get up to our if you go back to the
question our displacement equation i've
got velocity with respect to time
so it's a straightforward it's about as
straightforward and integration as you
can get
to integrate this up i'm going to say
integrating just so it's clear what i'm
doing
and what i'm going is just the
displacement equation
and let's just write our integral out
like so with respect
to time now of course just like you've
seen previously we're going to go ahead
do the integration and then we're going
to get a constant which we'll need
to evaluate so let's go ahead and do all
of that together
be careful here it's an exponential
right so what you want to do
is divide through by the uh
inside derivative and the inside
derivative in this case was
minus k right so therefore i'm going to
get when i divide through
by that uh negative a fifth i'll get
negative
75 e to the negative t
on five plus my constant and so i'm
ready to
evaluate that if i know a certain
displacement
at a certain time so i'm returning back
to my initial conditions
not initial conditions for velocity but
initial conditions
for displacement and when you have a
look up here um
does it give you any information about
where it's being fired from
and it looks to me like the answer is
not particularly
so therefore we can make the position
that's being fired from we can make that
the origin like why not
choose easy numbers if you can so i'm
going to say
setting uh original position as origin
if they don't define the origin for you
you'd better define it yourself
as the origin
what that tells us is t equals zero
implies x equals zero and i hope it's
not too obvious to see
in much the same way that we saw this um
e to the negative
zero and five became one you're just
going to get negative 75 here
you're gonna get zero on that left-hand
side so all you get left with
is that constant so that's going to
further imply
that the constant is 75 right
so ta-da we're kind of halfway there or
like at least a third the way there
because as you'll see
the next one is a bit more work i've now
got my horizontal displacement equation
so i'll pop the constant out the front
since it's a
subtraction that's attached to that
exponential term
and i'm good to go hooray i have x as a
function of time